[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna back here
for anime uproar and welcome to another
installment of our weekly anime news
cast the links are in the description
recommendations go in the comments and
by the way if you guys enjoy these
weekly videos be sure to leave a like
and drop me a line in the comments
because I'm always wondering whether you
find these videos useful first in anime
up renews our big QA video is finally up
so you can go and check that out right
now I'll leave the link in the
description making that video was a lot
of fun and it was all because of your
awesome comments and feedback so thank
you everybody who participated and be
sure to check that out also this
Saturday for our Code Geass stream goes
in and I decided that we would live
react to code mint the Code Geass
abridged series because neither of us
has actually seen it yet so we thought
it would be fun to react to the whole
series along with you guys live on
Saturday so be sure to tune in for that
on Saturday at 12 noon Eastern Standard
Time and finally we are planning our
very first anime upper twitch party for
this Sunday at 12:00 noon Eastern
Standard Time we're going to be playing
those online party games like those jack
box games so definitely come through and
hang out I will leave the link to the
twitch in the description so be sure to
follow us and come through on Sunday
it's going to be a lot of fun and we
might even have a few drinks you never
know and actually today on Tuesday at 5
p.m. Eastern Standard Time we will be
joining Briggs from all-day anime for a
special live stream on his channel about
the seven deadly sins anime season 2
news all the fake news surrounding it
and all that kind of stuff
our void Brix has been making excellent
7 Deadly Sins content lately and he's
built a great community on his channel
so if you're still not subscribed to him
be sure to check him out I will leave
the link in the description and speaking
of the seven deadly sins the English dub
blu-ray and DVD is now out for that
anime through Funimation so I will leave
the link in the description for all the
info last week Johnny Yong Bosch the
iconic English voice actor for lelouch
lamperouge in the dub version of
Geass was speaking at a panel at an
anime con in North Carolina and he was
actually asked by one of the fans what
his thoughts were on Code Geass getting
a sequel on the whole idea of code geass
season 3 from what we could tell Johnny
Yong Bosch seemed to express some doubts
about Code Geass coming back for another
season because he felt that the ending
of r2 was so great however he said that
he is hopeful that this is not just a
money grab he said that it's a risk but
he hopes that this risk will pay off and
that the third season will be as great
as the previous two so I'm really
wondering what you guys think about this
what do you think about Johnny Yong
Bosch has thoughts on code geass season
3 what are your own thoughts let me know
down in the comments and I want to thank
nobody for bringing this to my attention
in the comments on last week's video as
I mentioned last week in a recent news
article crunchyroll implied that an
important one punch man update could be
coming on May 11th however May 11th came
and went and even though I've been
checking the official Japanese one punch
man website the latest information there
is just that a one punch man
season two is currently in production
however we still don't have any specific
release dates in the comments on last
week's video
Sam journey pointed out that this latest
update could simply be referring to the
latest chapter of the one punch man
manga coming out in Japan so we still do
not have a release date for one punch
man season 2 which is the big news that
we are all really waiting for however we
do know that the anime is in production
it is official so we are hoping for that
official release date sometime soon and
of course here at anime ofor we will
keep you posted so stay tuned this week
our friend Brent from Brent's fandoms
uploaded a new video and this was a
guide to dealing with waifu and husbando
insults but this video was not only
hilarious it was also terrifying because
it gave birth to brands frightening
alter-ego shotgun Brinn oh no you did
can anyone stop her now we'll ran cafe
become brain cafe only time will tell
but I definitely recommend checking out
this video
and for all of you who are obsessed with
the smut Wendi meme and I know a lot of
you are because I see you into this
chord otaku vs. uploaded all arias video
this week the smog Wendy anime opening
this is a short video but it is also
hilarious and so well done you have to
check it out the new episode of the
Dragon Ball Z abridged series is out
this week from Team 4 star episode 58 is
live now and as usual it is full of
action and sexual innuendos so if that's
your thing
definitely watch this video and my
favorite a MV for this week is an MV by
a youtuber called u Zeus and this MV
features a mix of a whole bunch of
badass anime to the music of chop suey
by System of a Down as someone who
enjoys the music of systemö down and
like this song in particular I really
enjoyed this MV and I thought it was
really well put together however I will
give you a Gore warning there is a lot
of gore in this one but I will
definitely recommend watching it and
actually when I first stumbled on this
video it had only 16 views and one like
so let's show this guy some love the
link is in the description and that is
it for this week guys if you enjoyed
these videos be sure to LIKE and
subscribe I want to give a quick thank
you to original link for becoming our
ninth anime uproar patron and according
to forgotten 915 aka girl bro once we
get 25 patrons
we are officially becoming a cult so I
don't know how I feel about that but
we'll have to see and until next time
see ya space cowboys
you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]